randall and his team have tagged nearly
200 hammerheads
he tracks them using a network of
receivers like this one
dotted all over the eastern tropical
pacific
i'm filming him as he tries to add one
more to his tally
and there's no time to lose
[Music]
whoa that shark's got a hook in its
mouth
that shows these sharks are roaming
outside the protected area
and that's when they come into contact
with this fishing gear
at kokos in the last 20 years
around half the population has vanished
[Music]
worldwide scalloped hammerheads are
critically endangered
they are being fished out of existence
[Music]
we kill
more than 100 million sharks every year
to cut their fins off
and put them into soup
and if we continue the way we're going
shark species will go extinct
these underwater ecosystems they need
sharks to thrive
you know the sharks the top predators
they keep this whole thing in balance
epic adventures with birdie gregory a
disney plus day premiere september 8th
on disney plus
you